[Music]
I was the victim of a violent would in
August of 2016 I was coming out of a
deli in Chappaqua New York where I live
and I was walking out with a bagel and
iced coffee which was my regular routine
turned toward my car and all of a sudden
I heard a loud boom looked at my
shoulder s or blood gushing out and it
turned out I was hit by a shotgun from
an assailant that I didn't immediately
recognize cause I just mainly paid
attention to save my life and run back
into the deli where I was helped by
local customers and folks who worked at
the deli to make sure that the assailant
was not going to come into the the
restaurant to hurt me and maybe other
people and what I initially did was do a
back-of-the-envelope assessment of what
whether I was gonna live or not in fact
there was a customer right next to me
and said I'm gonna be all right
and I was thinking wait a second he's
not a doctor you know how does he know
but I said to myself what I'm a doctor
and so I thought to myself why I didn't
pass out I still could think okay I felt
that perhaps the pellets and I ended up
being shot 115 pellets that had missed
the vital organs because I wasn't you
know passing out so I had some
confidence immediately after I was shot
that I was I was going to live and
shortly thereafter
the police arrived arrested the
assailant then a local ambulance of
volunteer ambulance came and and took me
to the Westchester Medical Center which
had a trauma center where I was
evaluated and found you know that I was
I was going to
but there were several episodes that
were part of the initial of that that I
will never forget one was the heroism of
ordinary people who happened to be in
the deli that day some who ran toward
the assailant you know to make sure he
was not going to get away and he was not
going to come into the deli others you
know call the police and the ambulance
you know right away
and then when the police came they
showed courage going out to arrest the
assailant who had a shotgun and I'll
never forget you know that day and then
it turns out you know when I went to the
was taken to the hospital and I was
evaluated and I want to get to Mount
Sinai you know where I'm the Dean as
soon as it was safe as I was me about to
be transferred my son who's a doctor was
waiting outside my door with an with a
police officer officer Davenport and we
didn't know who he was but turned out he
was a local Newcastle police officer who
happened to be off-duty heard about to
shut this shooting came to the trauma
center in Westchester Medical Center
with the idea that he was going to
prevent any further violence upon me and
my family and he said to my son I wish I
just wish I was there to take the
bullets this is a man that didn't know
me didn't know my family was a hero and
he's somebody that I will never forget
and then I was taken to Mount Sinai
where I was admitted to the intensive
care unit and that's when the process of
recovery started when I was in the bed
at the Westchester Medical Center's
trauma center I started to think you
know who would who would shoot me and I
started thinking back and then you know
it occurred to me that you know maybe
there was a disgruntled faculty member
that we Mount Sinai had terminated about
6 or 7
years before that he had been found
guilty of scientific misconduct and that
led to the termination I had no contact
with that individual for six seven years
actually I barely knew him when he was
at Mount Sinai but I was thinking is it
possible that it was him and it turned
out that that was the person who shot me
I had been I have been studying
resilience for the last 25 years I also
study depression and post-traumatic
stress disorder and other such
conditions to develop new treatments but
about 25 years ago my colleague and I
Steve Southwick thought you know maybe
we could learn from people who had been
traumatized and either didn't develop
problems with anxiety or depression or
substance abuse or if they did they
recovered in other words they were
resilient so we ended up studying you
know hundreds maybe even thousands
people who by our definition were
resilient and they came from all
different ethnic groups socio-economic
groups all different kinds of trauma you
know ranging from a war to congenital
disease to victims of natural disasters
to victims of poverty and physical and
sexual abuse and through that all that
research both subjective and objective
type of research we had to find you know
what it takes to become resilient in
fact we published a book called
resilience the science of mastering
life's greatest challenges and through
that we identified factors in fact ten
factors that related to becoming a
resilient person and so here I got shot
I became a trauma victim and in fact
once you're a trauma victim you are a
trauma victim for life and one of the
things that occurred to me shortly after
I was shot in fact when I was in the
intensive care unit I thought you know
now I have to walk the walk now I have
to show whether I'm a resilient you know
person and over the course of my
recovery starting in the ICU I found a
lot of the factors that we had
identified from the Brazilian people we
studied and came to admire helped me so
in a very personal way we verified the
work that we had done and studying
resilience to actually help you recover
from a trauma my trauma